a great pitching matchup tonight and uh
you know obviously uh logan gilbert and
and cal rally have really you know
they've graced a lot of minor league
ballparks together as a battery uh but
this is the first time in the major
leagues uh that they'll be together
here's the wind-up and the one-two pitch
it is strike three called on the outside
corner and mark canaccord looking and
right away logan gilbert strikes out the
first batter that he faces tonight
against oakland
and kept lines one down the right field
line and it's headed for the right field
corner
kemp
checks back on haniger and kemp's gonna
have a one-out double
but just 11 starts into it and he's been
on quite a roll already he already looks
like he belongs here
well there's a slider yeah
all right you guys are maybe right from
time to time
well thank you for that big delivery
super mode here's a look at that slider
hot hitter in the lineup second
strikeout for gilbert after giving up
the double
that man right there chris bassett
taking the mound for his 20th start
looks like it hit pretty well out
towards left center field now it's going
to leave that's in the pan oh no it's
off the wall
now the mariners have hannegar on at
third base here's ty france with a
chance to give the mariners a lead
here's the stretch
and the 1-1 pitch swinging a ground ball
fair inside the bag at first and down
the right field line hannigar will score
easily from third a two-out rbi single
for ty france and the mariners have an
early one to nothing lead here in the
bottom of the first inning
and a good pitch there 95 and the battle
is won by bassette but the mariners get
a run ty france with a two odd rbi
single
no argument
a third strikeout for gilbert
here's the wind-up and the 3-2 pitch and
a swing and a miss by moreland he tried
to hold up on a fastball but it's strike
three and it's strikeout number four for
logan gilbert
that's a strike on the outside corner
and that is the first down
and speaking of which swing and a miss
and a really good fastball riding up and
away
for out number one it's the fifth
strikeout for gilbert one out here in
the third couple on one out tony kemp
who doubled back in the first setting to
extend his hitting streak to six games
they're going to get a base hit with a
runner and scoring position here and
this game is tied thanks to tony kemp
who's got two hits see if jed lowry can
untie this game as he stands in with two
outs 400 is the average with runners in
scoring position
best ball is pulled hard into right
bounces in front of hannigar for a base
hit and the a's are going to score two
as kenna and kemp cross the plate it's
3-1 oakland jed lowery delivers yet
again as he wraps a two-run single into
right field
there you go
these pick up three mirrors falling
behind three to one going into the
bottom of the third
and that's a swing and a miss by
crawford third strikeout for bassett
it's mitch haniger doubled off the left
center field wall missed the home run by
about two three feet his pit swung on
driven almost in the same spot deep
towards the pen on the track is loreanno
bye-bye
into the pen home run mitch haniger
and the mariners have closed the gap
it's three two a's here in the third and
lorianna climbed up the wall made a
valiant effort to go get it but mitch
rode it out of here into the pin to the
joy of all those folks out there who are
about 15 deep
[Applause]
swinging a ground ball two hoppers short
jp's got it second for one relay by
mortar first and it's in time to double
up garcia they get andrews at second and
double up garcia at first and that will
retire the side
good pitch a little movement on a
fastball at 93 miles an hour
torrent strikes out for the second time
[Applause]
and moore ends up striking out
so good curveball there by bassett gets
his fifth strikeout runner stranded and
we're on to the fifth
here's a swing and a ground ball to
short that counted by crawford slip and
slide on two hop throw to first and it's
in time to get lowery and that will
retire the side and jp was able to stay
with it
3-2 oakland the stretch
long hesitation now the 2-2 pitch and a
swing and a miss by crawford for strike
three
brings up right fielder mitch haniger
one a night for hannigan against bassett
a double land a home run
and here comes the 2-2 on the way
swinging to drive again deep center
field gloriana going back looking up
goodbye baseball to the batter's eye
straight away center mitch hager does it
again
and the mariners now lead the a's
it's the mariners 4 and oakland three
and what a night for mitch haniger
[Applause]
here's a breaking ball strike three
called
strikeout for casey sadler welcome back
to from sandler outside strike three
call
casey sadler welcome back your first
outing since april 30. he goes one two
three in the sixth
here's garcia he's over two he has
struck you out hit into a double play
one two pitch driven to right field
headed for the corner
and that baby's gone this game is tied
at four thanks to aramis garcia
crawford hits it to olson steps on the
bag for the first out this is going to
be a double play
[Applause]
not a boy atta boy matt olson that's
exactly
what needed to happen
because matt olson is two three plays
ahead of the game of baseball at any
given time so he was ready not only to
field that ball he knew he was going to
step on the bag and he knew to
anticipate the runner potentially
shutting it down
because of all of that so there goes the
arm swing deke you stopped him and now
he's dead to rights out there
and henniger on three pitches chases it
and how about sergio romo as they like
to say stay hot sergio
here's the set
and the seawall 3-2 pitch it is strike
three called on the inside corner and
there's one away here's the
right-handers
0-2 pitch out of the way and a swing and
a miss by lowry for strike three so
back-to-back strikeouts
[Applause]
here in seattle here's the 2-2 on the
way check swank strike three called on
the outside corner graven
strikes out chapman
[Applause]
strike three called on the outside
corner
and here comes mitch hanigar bases are
loaded with two outs and the pitch on
the way to henniger way outside of the
dirt gets on by garcia here comes kellik
on the score hands in the air and the
mariners went on a wild pitch 5-4